oh hello welcome to the video
um what were you doing 90 days ago 90
days ago you probably didn't consider
that you would be here today you
probably figured you'd be alive but you
probably also didn't consider what today
would feel like maybe you were
optimistic about the future maybe you
thought oh 90 days from now I'll live a
better life I'll do things better or
maybe you were just passing the time
doing your thing engaging in the
day-to-day grind and all of a sudden you
just showed up here and it's today now
but the weird thing is whether you
thought about today or not you still got
here it's still today time doesn't care
whether you spent the last 90 days going
to the gym every single day packing on
like 25 pounds of lean muscle time also
doesn't care whether you spent the past
90 days developing a problematic
OverWatch 2 addiction and ordering
takeout every single day and not
drinking enough water and getting
terrible sleep time's not concerned with
any of that it'll still just spit you
out on the other end of things right
here right now all of the pain of
overcoming mental resistance so that you
could do things that are beneficial to
you and all of the pleasure of comfort
that you engaged in by playing OverWatch
2 and eating takeout it's all gone now
it all doesn't matter you don't feel
that resistance anymore and you don't
feel the pleasure anymore all you have
is the result of those past 90 days so
what do you have to show for it
throughout our lives every single day
multiple times a day we sort of have
these Crossroads moments where our
prevailing habit seems to win out more
often than not maybe we're acclimatized
to just pouring hot water into a Ramen
packet and watching TV and we call that
lunch and it feels really weird to
actually put some effort into it eat
something cleaner and better for us so
we don't do it because it feels kind of
weird but that weird uncomfortable
feeling that apparently dictates
everything that you do it's gone now you
don't feel that feeling anymore right
here right now and if you just
disregarded that feeling and you did
what was good for you anyways you would
have still arrived here just the same
and all you would have is the result of
that good habit you would think better
you would look better you would feel
better and with bad habits it doesn't
matter how much pleasure you try to
siphon out of the world it doesn't
matter how long or how vigorously you
indulge in whatever your Vice of choice
is the feelings are always just
nullified by time anyways you no longer
feel the pleasure of 90 days ago all you
have is how you feel and who you are and
the life you live right here right now
so look around you like how did you do
how does it feel to be you because
everything you were up to for the past
90 days has been leading up to this
moment the life you live was already
decided for you by you now this might be
obvious to everybody this is sort of the
way the world works but I think if we
thought about this more often I think we
would make better choices because
naturally that gets you thinking 90 days
from now you're going to be 90 days
older and you're gonna feel exactly how
you do now or much worse or much better
so even if you feel terrible right now I
welcome you to embrace this moment some
people we just feel like passively
terrible sometimes we don't know why we
just feel trapped but it's always a huge
blessing to have Clarity to realize okay
I contributed to this my past 90 days
actually meant something and I have a
role to play to shape the next 90 days
and even if I don't want to do something
beneficial for me 90 day days from now
I'm not gonna feel that pain anyways and
if I want to go play OverWatch too
I'm not talking to myself obviously but
how cool is it it's sort of like a cheat
code when you realize this all of the
discomfort into building this better
present that I will be a part of 90 days
from now will be gone by then and all I
will have is the result of my effort
that's an exciting idea here's a really
cool visual illustration this is a life
calendar you've probably seen this in
some other YouTube video before I find
these really cool the entirety of this
calendar represents a 90-year life in
weeks so I'm 26 years old and this is my
life in weeks and this is what 90 days
looks like it's just such a tiny little
blip in the grand scheme of my life it's
such a manageable amount of time yet 90
days as we all know is a significant
amount of time to dramatically change
things you know three months of diligent
work on building a new habit or breaking
an old one whether that's spending time
in the gym or eating healthy or just
being more proactive at your work or
spending time with people or going for a
walk every day or drinking more water it
doesn't really matter 90 days of doing
that new thing can make your life look a
lot different at the other end of it but
at the same time when you look at this
calendar you can see that we don't have
an unlimited amount of 90 days we don't
have an unlimited amount of weeks our
life here on this Earth is finite it
matters tremendously that when we have
moments like this and we can kind of
sober up to the reality of the fleeting
nature of time that if we don't like how
we've been spending it as of late we can
redirect because
90 days from now you will be somewhere
God willing
so why not make that somewhere you want
to be
I just want to give a big thank you to
athletic greens for sponsoring this
video you guys have heard me say it a
billion times ag-1 is by far my favorite
health supplement and that's because
there is no competing with its
nutritional profile it tastes great I
have it every single day and it makes me
feel so good it is packed with over 75
vitamins minerals Whole Foods Source
superfoods and adaptogens in every
single scoop it ensures that you're
giving your body everything that it
needs to feel focused and energetic
throughout the day and why wouldn't you
want that and since it's sourced from
Whole Foods it's extremely bioavailable
which means that when you drink it you
don't just urinate it out your body can
actually absorb it and use it in its
various faculties it's just an extremely
high quality source of nutrition so if
you want to join me in feeling fantastic
throughout the day then if you use my
link in the description below you'll
also get a year's supply of the vitamin
D3 and K2 complex which I also have
every single morning as well as five ag1
travel packs with your first purchase so
go ahead and take advantage of that link
below and thank you again to athletic
greens for sponsoring this video If you
enjoyed this video and you liked it then
hit the like button because when you
actually
hit the like button it shoves my bald
head into other people's home pages
helping them out which also helps me out
so it's just a win-win for everybody if
you hit the like button if you're
lurking here and this is the thousandth
time that you've seen my face consider
hitting the Subscribe button why not I
like more subscribers it gives me a
sense of validation completely
artificially which I should not
rely upon thanks for watching